yesterday. This entire bogus voter fraud narrative
from the Trump campaign that claims Joe Biden
stole the election came to an incredible climax
as Rudy Giuliani and other Trump lawyers held
a press conference in Washington, D.C. that
was beyond parody. First of all, Rudy Giuliani
appeared to. During the event, first he was
sweating uncontrollably and then it looked
like he was bleeding out of both of his ears,
it actually apparently was melting hair dye.
I mean, the optics of this are absurd. He
had what looked like dried blood down the
sides of his face, what reportedly was hair
dye that under the hot lights in the basement
of the RNC or wherever they were, was starting
to melt. The content was no more sensible.
During the press conference, they blamed the
following entities in part for stealing the
election from Donald Trump, Democrat run cities,
Democrat mayors, Dominion Voting Systems.
Here we go now, Cuba, Venezuela, Hugo Chavez,
Nicolas Maduro, poll workers, election officials.
And I'm probably forgetting some oh, George
Soros, which we will get to know. Good right
wing conspiracy is complete until you include
a rich Jewish man in it.
That's almost a requirement at this point
in time. First, did they present proof of
fraud? They did. Not just more complaints
about circumstances. Take a listen.
Night seminar, 800000 in Pennsylvania. Somehow
he lost Pennsylvania. We have statisticians
willing to testify, but that's almost statistically
impossible to have happened in the period
of time that it happened. But, of course,
that's just speculation, right?
It is speculation. I'm glad Rudy acknowledges
that.
And it continued which to any experienced
investigator prosecutor would suggest that
there was a a plan from a centralized place
to execute these various acts of voter fraud,
specifically focused on big cities and specifically
focused on, as you would imagine, big cities
controlled by Democrats.
I don't know guys, big cities controlled by
Democrats starting to sound like shorthand
for places with lots of black people talking
about Philadelphia and Detroit and others,
then this is real. This is not a skit. Rudy
reenacted a scene from the film My Cousin
Vinny, and then casually accused Joe Biden's
campaign of committing crimes and fraud. Take
a look.
Probably the closest they got is from here
to the back of that room. We could do like
a did you all watch my cousin Vinny? You know,
the movie. It's one of my favorite war movies
because he comes from Brooklyn. And when the
nice lady who said she saw and then he he
says to her, how many fingers do how many
things will I go to? And she says, Three.
Well, she was too far away to see. It was
only two. These people were further away than
my cousin Vinny was from witness. They couldn't
see a thing. Now, I don't know. You're going
to tell me that 60 people are lying. They
didn't just tell me this. They swore under
penalty of perjury, which is something no
Democrat has ever done.
So this is probably a good time to talk about
affidavits as evidence versus affidavits as
proof. They talk about the fact that they
have affidavits as proof that there was fraud.
Really important to understand this. An affidavit
is a form of evidence which much like testimony
from a witness, could be admissible or not,
depending on the specifics, depending on the
court and the circumstances. Sometimes a court
will say, OK, we've seen the affidavit, we
need to bring in the witness to actually testify
to this in court. And an affidavit, much like
witness testimony, could be ruled out as hearsay
or not. OK, so the fact that affidavits exist,
they claim, is proof of fraud when it is not
your affidavit may or may not be used as evidence.
Your affidavit, much like testimony, could
be considered by a judge or jury. Credible
or not, credible affidavits are not proof.
All right. There are sworn affidavits about
Bigfoot. What that means is that an individual
is willing to testify to that. It doesn't
mean that the testimony would necessarily
be credible or proof of anything. Rudie then
goes on to say that, listen, if you don't
count Wayne County, which is where Detroit
is in Michigan, Trump wins that state.
Take a listen to this in one 80-20. So you
see a change as a result of the of of the
election in Michigan if you take out Wayne
County. So it's a very significant case.
Now, it just so happens that Wayne County
has one point seventy five million people
in it and Michigan's total population is ten
million. So what Rudy is saying is, if you
for some reason, if you were to not count
a county that has nearly 18 percent of the
state's population, then the other candidate
would win.
Oh, OK. That's. Not how this works, though,
that's a very strange thing to say, and then
Rudy Giuliani says that they are looking at
potentially trying to overturn the results
in this long laundry list of states go, which
and we have a significant number of allegations
in the state of Virginia.
I don't know yet whether the number in Virginia
will reach the number that can turn the election
in the states that we have indicated in red,
Georgia, Pennsylvania, Michigan, Wisconsin,
Nevada and Arizona, we more than double the
number of votes needed to overturn the election
in terms of provable illegal ballots. All
you got to do to find out if I'm misleading
you at all is to look at the lawsuit.
They had a map up as well with those states
in red, delusional. Then in came Cydney Powell,
who is another one of Trump's attorneys. And
she this sounded like a Sean Hannity monologue,
talking about take the country back, because
Trump won to know right now that we will not
be intimidated.
American patriots are fed up with the corruption
from the local level to the highest level
of our government. And we are going to take
this country back. We are not going to be
intimidated. We are not going to back down.
We are going to clean this mess up. Now, President
Trump won by a landslide. We are going to
prove it. And we are going to reclaim the
United States of America for the people who
vote for freedom.
This is a lawyer supposedly take the country
back. Trump won by a landslide. This is insane.
And then it got really wild. Another lawyer,
Jenna Ellis, took the mic and she started
attacking the media for how they were going
to report on this completely unhinged event.
Take a look at this.
And I'm the senior legal adviser to the Trump
campaign. And I'd like to just explain now
where we've been and where we're at and what
you can expect from this process. So what
you have heard, I'm sure, in the fake newspapers
tomorrow will be one of two things. Either
there was not sufficient evidence that we've
presented or we spoke too long. OK, so what
you've heard now is an basically an opening
statement. This is what you can expect to
see when we get to court to actually have
a full trial on the merits, to actually show
this evidence in court and prove our case.
This is not a law and order episode where
everything is neatly wrapped up in 60 minutes.
You know, another difference from law and
order episodes is that law and order episodes
contain actual crimes. We still have no evidence
that any crimes took place here. And then
when the questions started, Rudy Giuliani
was still melting. The hair dye was just running
down his face, looking like he had two ears
that were bleeding.
And then, of course, as I said, no good right
wing conspiracy theory is complete until you
can include a rich Jewish man in it, which
Rudy did during the Q&A portion of the event,
talking about George Soros with a company
whose chairman is a close associate and business
partner of George Soros, the biggest donor
to the Democrat Party, the biggest donor to
Antifa and the biggest donor to Black Lives
Matter. My goodness, what do we have to do
to get you to give our people the truth?
It always is a better conspiracy from the
standpoint of the right. If you can pull in
a rich Jewish man, it's a better conspiracy.
And then Rudy Giuliani caps this off by saying,
listen, none of us are engaging in fantasy,
but Trump actually won Pennsylvania, Pennsylvania
and Michigan.
I don't know what you need to wake you up.
To do your job and inform the American people,
whether you like it or not. Of the things
they need to know, this is real. It is not
made up. It is not. There's nobody here that
engages in fantasies. I've tried 100 cases.
I prosecuted some of the most dangerous criminals
in the world. I know crimes. I can smell them.
You don't have to smell this one. I can prove
it to 18 different ways. I can prove to you
that he won Pennsylvania by 300000 votes.
I can prove to you that he won Michigan by
probably 50000 votes.
No fantasies here, guys. Just Rudy claiming
Trump won states that Trump obviously lost.
Some say this is merely sad. Reportedly, Rudy
is charging 20 grand a day to represent Trump.
So if he's actually getting paid that Trump
has a reputation for not paying people that
work for him, Rudy is making a fool out of
himself. Yes, but he's potentially being compensated
quite handsomely.
Parodies of themselves. How do you make a
satire of that? If your Saturday Night Live,
you can let me know what your thoughts are.
I'm on Twitter
at
David Pakman,